quoi
elles sont parquées de décembre
sa démarche au paraguay sera c'est pat
rigal et 2000 à benghazi façon séparée
risque pas grand chose a dit
je suppose a rien de détroit et la boxe
à 1200 maintenant ça sera pire
j'ai aperçu que les photos comme ça en
fin de journée c'est parce vachement
bien
récup'art pas trop trop bas à l'ebit est
quoi ca
ok tu veux pouvoir commencer aussi
utilisable
m
de quoi s'était fait opérer yeux quoi se
séparent qu'est ce que tu as vu mais
privé de vacances voire babula non gardé
des parts d'un buzz d'autres et noir
devaient avoir les yeux sont à
télécommande et c'est bien là un peu par
bp de récupérer grâce et bientôt
c'est un peu travaillé sublimissime ça
c'est aussi con c'est beau ça c'est très
beau de voir qu'ici que c'est l'enfant
passait devant vinci espère d'ailleurs
déplacé on se rend compte qu'il y aura
sa part étudiants quittaient ce que c
est
brad lidge a rappelé m c'est du reste un
pari qu'il est assez incroyable
oui un flair vrai allez on recommence
werner
hop
eric lepleux première en larges trous
d'eau enfin mon petit fils parce que tu
te rappelles quand tout allait rentrer
exactement ce que fait à l'heure c'était
supplie ne sont pas qu'un peu enfin un
ou deux chez vous s'il vous plaît
par ce pseudo
de sport deux ans profitant regarde
aussi bien c'est bien ça va c'est bien
c'est bien franck besnier algérienne
bernard biger super génial du mien
bâle
avons nous pas [ __ ] des liens la dpj
panneaux zilina et lambert
bon allez petit des cassos quand on a un
petit frère à bernier coûte au delà de
votre coeur est maintenant à rappeler en
fait pas son ambition
voilà